ich bin ehrlich gesagt geschockt von dem
was ich dort gehört habe er wiederholt
das was er im tweet gesagt aber in einem
ganz anderen ton van trinh mit großen
staaten schreibt ausgeschrieben
geschrieben
hier hat an einem ganz sachten ton
gesagt frankly dass frankie h ist ja
eine einschätzung heißt also meiner
meinung nach und du denkst es kann immer
noch wahnsinnige und krass gesagt ja
bislang habe ich vor dass wir gerade
gesagt und ist es so deswegen habe ich
voll dazu geraten erst mal die rede
abzuwarten vor der rede sagte wir haben
gesehen wie alle allermeisten menschen
werden das nicht gesehen haben und die
daraus destillierte nachricht ist trump
klärt sich zum sieger der wahl mit
vorwärts hat die anmeldung das hat er
getan
leben kann man den vorbehalten ehrlich
gesagt schon einmal so viel verständnis
für joe biden hätte sind nur das ist es
wert auch so als würde sich in fußball
drehen hat bei einem
champions-league-spiel zum
champions-league-gewinner erklären
obwohl noch die verlängerung kommt also
sozusagen das ist ungefähr das was die
demokraten wollen die sagen die sagen
wir wollen nicht 90 wollen nicht fünf
zweimal 15 minuten verlängerung sondern
wir hätten gerne noch die schiedsrichter
gesagt machen aber die demokratie ist
aber schon viel länger und entschuldige
aber wichtig ist auch einmal zu sagen
das hat so beiden dort in seiner
ansprache im nicht gesagt er hat nicht
gesagt ich will so und soviel
verlängerung er hat gesagt es ist noch
nicht klar als ich sehr zurückhaltend
geäußert er hat nicht behauptet dass er
irgendeine wahl schon gewonnen hätte
sondern setzen müssen ab heute mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren